same thing with you're going to sit in
your standing exercise for an
hour you see and now it's an it turns
into an endurance Fest how can you do it
can you right um like can you put some
rounds into this 3in circle that's
that's not the true test so the stand
your meditation you're going to do it an
hour it's it's misleading it shouldn't
take an
hour it should be in instantly in the in
the drop of a sword cut you should be
able to do the release and draw okay so
I tell the the recruits you know
eventually hey we can't throw the
instructor under the bus but I say hey
you know this is a
Marksmanship skill we want to see how
accurate you can place around but we
can't let go of all the other Mechanics
for you to place
around um because you're not going to
have 10 seconds 5 Seconds between shots
that's not going to happen and you're
not going to do that when somebody's
shooting at you you're going to be
pressing that trigger in a blind panic
uh but you're going to miss that's
what's going to
happen so then you know they don't know
that and so you have to come there and
go boom boom boom boom boom and put five
rounds in 2 seconds or less in the 1 in
part part of the Bulls L you see you get
it cuz it's
ideal if I can't stand perfectly still
on the Range which they are with no one
shooting at me and make those kind of
splits on and have bullet holes going to
bullet holes I'm going to miss in real
life just like if I can't release until
I have an hour of it I'm not going to do
this in a technique I'm not going to do
it um anywhere in real life where people
are pressuring me that I'm going to
contest I'm going to do the opposite of
what I'm supposed to do
so these pointers that you're given is a
way of zeroing you in you know in the
same way like um I'll come by somebody
who's uh keeps regripping their grip so
they'll get your ideal grip what you
what's your ideal grip all right and
they'll get something and then I'll come
and I'll fix them put just like I go put
your posture here shift your weight here
you see when I push on your shoulder you
see so they'll do some weird grip and I
go no no no let's get that hand up there
all right are you good yep and then I'll
come draw a
line across their hands their two
hands don't change that line see you get
it okay whatever you do you have to make
your shots stop using the full three in
use the one inch in the
middle and you cannot take that line
apart does that make sense okay so that
line is like the pointers that you're
giving if you if she in this case it was
a woman if she doesn't break that grip
see she gets to keep her trigger finger
in the same place on the trigger she now
gets consistency on the trigger
press she also then doesn't move her
site picture which you can't don't move
your sight picture see she has to
control
recoil too cuz she doesn't let the gun
jump in her hands it starts to fix a
whole bunch of things um without them
actually realizing
all that they're fixing with the single
line that's dra across
it what most instructors want to
do
is they'll tell them to slow
down no no we can't slow down okay
that's not the drill so hence I don't
like to
do
long long sessions of release because
it's almost
okay but it is a
technique um but I think it has to be
appropriately applied to the Venna so
for example if I have a
shooter who is so scared of the bang
which is very common that they can't use
the mechanics you see they just there's
no way the the explosion of the round
going off a fo and a half from their
face make some blink all this kind of
stuff you see that there's no not enough
Consciousness in order to be trained not
enough awareness in order to be
trained so that person I'll say slow
down but my goal is I just want them to
get used to the explosion I really don't
even care sometimes I've taken those
shoters when I'm driving the bus and
take away all the targets and shoot into
the backdrop you get it cuz the real
problem is the explosion until we can
fix the fear stter response we there's
no point in going past that so when you
take
somebody and you give them a solo
drill sometimes it's just to get them in
the
ballpark but solo drills have a problem
and the problem
is I I don't know what I'm working
on they don't understand that they're
getting acclimated to the explosion you
see and they might even feel bothered by
the fact I'm not giving you a tet do you
get that just shoot I don't don't even
aim sometimes I tell them don't even aim
just make the gun go off right but it
gets you there in the end in the long
run so the takeaways here is are
training H can never lose
sight of the utilitarian or practical
end and we have to be very careful about
the drills that we
use
um and a lot of drills in modern iika
did just pass down with no understanding
of what is the end what is the Practical
utilitarian thing I'm not supposed to
lose and this is Complicated by the fact
that modern ioka don't know that anymore
they don't they're not fighting with it
nor are they living with it either so
they practice one thing inside the dojo
and outside the dojo they practice
contestation all day long as we had
several talks on that
okay
um so in my
opinion solo drills are are often touted
like you got to do your solo work you
got to do your solo
work I like to save solo drills to the
to the we're going to do them but
they're not the emphasis of the training
you're going to do them um like we did
Zen but Mo it's only like a half hour
and then the rest we're doing partner
drills okay and the partner
drills make more gross what we're trying
to work
on there's still pointers in
there um and then we can work on those
things and this is why we don't do we
don't really do the boat rolling
exercise here um we have done it but we
don't really do it whereas in other
places it's part of warmup you know you
do your class and and you do all this
stuff um
and as part of warmup but as we've seen
in the in the group people don't know
what they're doing and and now you're
doing something that is totally contrary
to what we're supposed to be doing just
like those new Shooters like you're
taking 10 second splits between RS no
this is this is pointless this is
absolutely pointless right now so I have
taken the solo drill of the boat rowing
exercise and put it in the beginning
of the C cultivation drill set and then
we move past it to see what can you do
with it okay and then from there you can
take it into the techniques okay
so we
have we start with a standing drill
which is I'm going to take young aspect
and release it to the midfoot
there is a skill that is very
important in Kona and that's ground
vectoring okay and we so we want to know
how to do that and ground vectoring is
I'm going to take your y
aspect and divert
it along with my y aspect down to the
ground to the midfoot so tactically in
Kon MAA as I said at the beginning we
use the back midfoot for k
in fighting you're going to you're going
to have to use all whatever foot it is
one foot even a toe a total worth okay
but in Kian Wasa it is probably 99% of
the time the back and foot so we want to
know that okay so we do our releasing
drill I take my young aspect drill one
and I release it to the midfoot and it
should it has to be fast speed Al life
fast okay I don't know what to feel feel
I don't not sure what that is I don't
understand why changing my grip is
slowing me down right so we got to get
you this so we're going to amplify it
and we use partner drills um and I think
it's interesting that um in one of those
talks uh Adam misner who has people do
Solo solo standing drill for like
hours um he said his teacher no longer
does Sol drills and goes to partner
drills um and Domo said that to about
his teacher and I think because they
landed on exactly what I landed on this
is this makes the aspects we're working
with gross enough for the practitioner
to get more in the ballpark there's a
lot of self-deception that comes from
solo drills in the same way that there's
a lot of self-deception when I let you
shoot however slow you want and and
you're satisfied with um rounds all over
a 3-in circle with no stress of someone
shooting at you you see so we use the
the partner drills that way so we know
the boat rowing exercise has this this
motion to it okay um but you can see at
this point in o sense's boat rowing he's
on the back foot okay what does everyone
do they emphasize this this part you see
and so they're here like that and they
kind of
go like throwing themselves forward but
this is the part that you're working
with this resets the drill this part is
in the Techni everywhere okay so we go
to drill
two I you should start speed of life I
drop my young aspect on the mid
foot she adds her young aspect and I
conjoin that to the back mid
foot and the metric that we're using
here is if you're rounding on the back
mid foot the front foot is irrelevant
therefore it can be on the ground off
the
ground and she cannot move me the metric
is not not to be moved the metric is
Young aspect on the back foot and it is
coincidental with her not being able to
move me I don't want to test myself with
hey shoot within that 3in Circle that's
not the true goal okay I should be able
to do that but that's not the true goal
so the goal here is not to stop myself
from being moved the goal is to combine
and conjoin her young aspect with my
aspect on the midfoot and to do this
I can be very relaxed she can push and
it it doesn't
matter I'm doing the drills hence I tell
you guys that when you feel muscle
tension and you can so here I am in that
muscle
tension and then I'll release that
without losing positional
Integrity it'll
drop and I should be able to just drop
it like I'm hold something and I let
go that is more you're working on the
drill than you doing this okay so
[Music]
maybe I feel the tension I release and I
get push I say you're closer to getting
it and if you don't get pushed and you
keep muscle tension
okay does that make sense okay so here
is fipi
that's that part right there and here's
the partner drill so you're not
bullshitting yourself on whether you're
taking y aspect and able to conjoin it
with your y aspect and send it down to
the okay so
that's this part in drill two all right
so let's try that and then I'll show you
the moving forward part okay try that
again for
and if you want more sensation of what's
Happening you just increase your part's
young aspect you can tell them more more
more push more and see does tension
rise does positional Integrity be is it
maintained is it maintained through
tension or through young aspect
conjoining and going down to the back
mid
foot e
so use your use your train partner tell
them
more they're not
opponents if they're pushing
laterally like Margaret was doing that
one day tell them hey push a little
straighter on me please okay
and observe what you feel where does my
tension come am I in a bracing angle Etc
switch every two not
for and and you have your areas that the
teacher gave you to focus on
okay and even as you coach or you you
direct your UK be observant of what
requests you're making because we also
know ultimately the shape is
irrelevant okay so your requests are
probably shape relevant
which will eventually have to be taken
away
okay for
okay all right so as I said BR we're
going to do today more like a like a
moving lecture okay so don't don't sit
soart let's let's
talk all right so what and you feel free
to stand it's fine okay so what anything
come up any questions just like that
shooter wants to know you know I think I
told you the other day that one of the
recruits came up and he all like I just
I can't find my Red Dot you know that's
going to slow you down see um in a real
gunfight you can't find a red dot you're
going to just press around you're going
to miss got it that member the the Cadre
lead doesn't didn't show people how to
find the
red he doesn't know how to teach people
to find a r it so I pulled this kid
aside and here's here's how you find and
I explain it just like this just like we
do that kid's Top Shot
okay it's in all of us but the
information can complicate what we're
doing so that's why I want you to feel
free and not just sit there
because how how we got to this stuff
nowadays is because everyone was fine
not knowing what they're doing do you
get it um so that's why we're doing
today like a discussion okay so what did
you feel at this point right
now you feel the muscle
tension anyone
knock I feel it mostly
when I'm pushing
especially here yeah I can't get I can
it's been like this for years yes I
don't feel that on my left side but on
the right
side okay so take pointers that you've
heard we've had this one mentioned this
week and what did you hear the teacher
say to someone else who had that same
point you
remember did you have
sides you don't have sides okay if we
have size we're not doing we're not
doing it okay um same thing I'm going to
let you get in there and I will work to
reconcile your sides but that's
indicative that I'm not yet doing it
okay um just like the muscle tension is
indicative as I said when I say shape
doesn't matter if shape doesn't matter
then I don't have size do you see that
in the Practical end of this if I want
to do
this um let's say
martially if I have the shape I'm at a
great disadvantage if I can find the
release and the ground Vector from any
position in any Vector I'm more Marsh
viable than if I have to be one way to
get it to whatever is going on if I'm
going to do this socially or spiritually
the same thing if I can't find the
release no matter what the environment
and the situation is then I can't really
do the drill you get that so keep in
mind I remember the teacher said shape
doesn't matter okay um and then you're
just training as you're going along work
on what you can work on get in there
release you
have okay you can also do some tests
though
okay so we're going to do uh she's
pushing we're going to do drill two
again and I can come up on one leg and
I'm not doing the Christopher H thing
see what I'm doing she's holding me
up I here I am standing with my posture
and I can take that
LE she's pushing and then you could you
could go any leg she can't push me
over Okay so let's try the one leg and
it's going to get more gross and you're
going to
feel whoa I I had tension any somewhere
because the structural displacement is
only possible from the Yang over writing
my y turning me y but if I can
internalize her y vector
it doesn't override me this is the this
is the the yinong theory and its
reconciliation
yinong
isn't a movement of lerong to Y so to
speak it is I stop all Yin Yong okay I'm
not there at all so she's
pushing doesn't I I don't I want to go
to the confusion she's not
confused
but it doesn't change what you're
pushing is whether my foot is down or my
foot is not down and in some way that's
a little weird okay so we'll try try
this and you'll see usually what you're
going to see is that um along with not
ground vory you have weak weak corners
and those give first
okay let's get some Awareness on these
weak what I'm calling Corners okay so
let's try
it do the first drill and then simply
pick the leg up
okay and again this is the reward part
the most important part of the boat
rowing exercise
let's move your team this way Virginia
and when you go on one leg there should
not be an increase in young at the grip
that's you leaning on them okay right
right Virginia you didn't feel an
increase when I went on one it felt
exactly the same as the first one
if you if you uh just to skip more if
you feel the increase in the Yong when
they go on one leg let go and you'll
they'll be able to see that ah yeah I
was leaning on them okay if they don't
fall forward they were doing it but you
shouldn't have felt an increase in y
keep the drove up
okay start in the first drill you're
pressing think
let's switch RS
and notice the
turn that comes
first okay and on day one remember it
was that rotation that we were talking
about do you remember that when your
elbow was out and it would turn you and
that that's that that's what I would
call a Rec corn so what this drill is
telling me is this part is not in my
downward descending of my own young
aspect and now if we look
why we're going to use your know Theory
here it's turning you right that means
it's
turnable what's making it turnable is
you're pushing on her but she has
greater young mechanics and so this
yields to it you guys understand that
okay so
by us not
turning it's indicative that we're not
turnable and by us not being turnable
it's indicative that I'm not contesting
the
grip you get it and now I'm doing the
drill which is Young aspect is coming
into me and being converted down okay so
every time we
lose what we're trying to accomplish
here it's giving light to the fact here
I am contesting they have greater young
mechanics and I'm the universe is
working its way out and go you're Yin
should okay so that's what you're
working on and none of that comes out in
this none of that comes out until you
you can feel that you know I am grounded
I I can feel that everything is
organized then then you can do this
drill but you know what you don't have
to do that drill everything is doing
whatever it is you don't need the boat
rolling exercise for that kind of
exercise okay um another one you can
do sometimes this one is is more
difficult but another one you can do
she's driving driving driving and she
lets go and I don't go fly forward you
can do that one too okay so let's try
that one it's a little less difficult
than the other one but you really have
to push push push
okay let
go and all we're trying to do is make
the backward motion of the boat roll
exercise an actual viable
drill yes
so again if we look at that in
the why did I come
forward right because I am contesting at
the grip right and when the grip goes
in I came forward rather than
internalizing his y I was pushing on his
Y and when that goes away you'll come
forward okay that's what we're trying to
look at here okay
try you're on the back foot
for
for for
okay
um so again we we taking the booing
exercises
making the as more growth so I can
observe
myself so that I'm actually doing what
I'm supposed to be doing so that I
actually achieve a Bible practice at the
end okay um so what should I be doing in
this drill I should be doing the same
thing in the standing drill but I
probably wasn't see and if I'm doing uh
drill two here I'm supposed to be
something but there's some
room just like there was so much wiggle
room in this that people change what it
is okay there's some little room here
but the
teacher can modify it the teacher
understands what the end goal is can
modify it to make even drill two more
gross so they can put you on one leg
they can have the UK let go but you can
tell
when it's there's a I'm hold I'm
fighting
rning you know or even you like you
doing
that day after day after day it's not
going to be uh today Saturday so it's
loud long day you get it but Monday go
right back to this so what are you
thinking you're
thinking that release
is that got it it's not that
which you've been told a million times
okay
um take last night's TR or last night's
work chaos is erupting did you see me
go no more chaos or did you see me work
not get played by what was going on and
take control this situation which which
I this is a kind of retre you see um
this is that idea that um the gooey soft
likeo that everything's
Yin Can you push me over no you see that
it's not it's not y it's not
weakness it's just not
contestation that's that's the
difference okay um so you have to be
careful because a lot of people that are
doing their spiritual training
have
misunderstood um the Christ
teaching where this just
this weak total weakness okay and then
when you look at those people under
conditions that are not conducive to
your weakness what do they do they
contest so we saw in this sh Calla video
what happened when that guy was pushing
on him he did exactly what someone does
with no
training how how long did it take you to
learn that all right like you were
probably born with that you know what I
mean so same thing as I
said one of the people there working
with
us could smell the riot starting and he
started yelling at these people and
that's just uping everybody's emotions
you see but he has a business on life
coaching okay this is weird so the same
thing with in the
shawa
somehow all his Harmony in his
choreographed
ukemi is doesn't function in reality
just like a new shooter that's doing 10c
splits this is not going to function in
reality okay and that is being revealed
in in the turn or the need to do this
I'm not quite there okay so we do the
next row rather than going to the boat
we're going to do another the next row
okay so I go to the back of the boat
roll exercise and then I'm going to come
forward this way
so I take this part and forward this
part and forward this
part this
part side note martially you do this
catching a lot this is how you catch the
young aspect catch it boom out it comes
it's in the boat boing exercise so take
the sword work we did
right we're
here
and their sword or their Joe's coming in
remember I
reached and the back foot stepped that
was the catch boom came around
underneath it and hit with the kitty go
if you stay
still you're going to get a touch okay
so we had
also the EOL
C it's in
everything it's in the boat
roll but we going to go
slow
transfer
transfer okay let's try drill
fre this is going to amplify our
gooiness and our turning our
contestation okay because the Y value is
going to increase as we go forward and
if I'm not reconciling it you'll see the
effects of the Amplified y TR
don't don't don't add to
it just shift shift
forward so do that again
Chris this turn
here is where go back go back okay and
you go and you turn you see so your your
catch is on a turn but your catch needs
to be just on a
shift okay
so that's it so you can feel you see
that it it it got compromised there
right because a y value is
there and this is on the very
lightweight we put you with
ad only cuz you're external right now if
you were internally it doesn't matter
you feel like her she feels like Ronin
it doesn't matter but externally it does
matter okay and we want to amplify the
gross
cues don't push just
shift they're they're not the metric you
just go to the back foot you come to the
front foot
don't turn do you feel feel that turn
Adam that he did back
foot you're not quite on the back
foot turn you're turning okay so now
guess analyze your own performance why
won't you go all the way on the back
foot think about
it anyone he feels like he going he he
you feel like you go backwards because
before you settled there you see you you
settled
there you got yourself all organized and
then you can hold that but now we're
going take him and move him and then
move him okay and this though is the
boat rowing exercise closer to it
pressure move it move it
okay got it so it's a little harder okay
but you have to get to the back foot and
you have to get forward if you're doing
your AR you coming in with whatever and
you're here you see when you could been
here you see that difference you feel
press yes okay
go you got to go all the way back to the
back foot just like in drill two not
halfway there
without turning turning you're trying
not to go not to go backwards
right and then just sh forward ignore
what happens to
him
for for
your G for
tension for
all right so let's do that your left arm
and we'll watch
here okay so at the end is your little
bracing angle and it's it she's be
moved it'll give you the sense like that
like those beginner Shooters when you
finish the drill and you go oh yeah yeah
everything's in the 3in circle you get
it but
take you to get it why did you use the
full 3 in it's not practical you get it
or your gooiness is now coming into play
here the gooiness that you had won't let
you actually do this this part and we'll
see
later that external pushing on her is
going to not serve you in the we can
again modify this one right so we catch
one leg and then in okay and that way I
got to be all the way back okay and I'll
amplify that one you'll probably feel
better for it because you're going to
bring your weight to that part you see
so you here you'll catch and then you'll
go down you see that but that's not what
what I did so I catch and I'm
here okay see if you can do that and see
where we get here try that one
[Music]
three and please be in the middle of the
m for
and then what do you think that UK can
do let go you're going back cuz you're
clearly not still on the back foot and
leaning on him
okay there's that turn again
when to let go is when they're on the
back foot
let go when he's on the when he goes to
the back
F yeah just let go oh
yeah see how you're you don't want to go
back there okay but that that moment a
couple of things martially cuz we have a
an end right just like the new shooter
I'll use that 3in Circle and to you know
allow you to work on your shooting
mechanics but you can't milk the drill
okay because there's a practical end
here well this is your push drrive that
we were working with the whole time
versus your step Drive okay you're doing
she's doing her you see as opposed to
I'm pushing into that so the
Jo all the uh attacks we doing is all
off the push drag not
the uh the ability to come on one leg
means that I can move and I don't have
to wait for your weight to go off of me
for me to move again which came up in
the to the Backle I keep moving okay um
so it's that part's all in
there but you can see the instructor is
constantly monitoring for what your
body's doing nobody's trying to be an
nobody is trying to
say I think this is the way to go but we
do things we deviate from what we're
doing and the instructor has to bring
you back in like that shooter isn't
going you know what I actually think
it's better if I change my grip all the
time they just can't keep it together
okay so hence the other drills so this
one it catches more
immediate and the reason for this is
this is yes an exter external catch but
in order for it to function correctly
it's an internal catch cuz if you just
do this you see you you did yield but
you didn't Yi all the way because
internally you weren't uh receiving the
young so the drill four is more
immediate and what will happen is if you
are doing it
externally externally there's not much
in her because there wasn't much y build
up and so there's not much projection
but internally you'll get more out of it
so it is the boat
exercise but shrunk okay all right try
it the catch has the internal aspect not
pure the external
aspect again it's very quick catch right
right away project right away
you got to catch first you just ran into
him with the with the Y
[Music]
okay
so assess always assess your own
performance okay what did you what do
you think
so as instru I go yeah this is too too
far the the parts that we were working
on weren't achieved yet and so this
drill is now not able to do it okay so I
have a
shooter who can't stop breaking their
grip or I have a that start I got to get
that problem and then we can go on okay
that shooter is still improving the one
who I took away all Targets and is
getting acclimated to the explosion is
still progressing to the shooter
who's doing this kind of stuff that will
never ever translate okay so if you look
at the other drills from here go on I
I'm now moving going to move towards her
you see and do do that same
drill this takes away all external catch
do you see that the only way I'm
catching is internal because I'm moving
after do you understand okay so what'll
happen at your level is you're just
going to run at her like this kind of
thing is not the same thing enough you
you will get displays okay so for shits
and giggles let's just try it but you
should have already realized that's
happening right here the catch part I'm
missing the projection part I can
replicate with an external contestation
you see that and as I said the most
important part of the boat rolling
exercise is the rearward part which
makes modern understanding of the boat
ring exercise the forward part
emphasize as I posted in that video
Terry Dobson is literally
here is going back and he's going
forward emphasizing that he's this close
to the founder master and he's doing
something different okay just imagine
now Generations distant no teacher
there's no
way you know why we've ended up where
We've Ended up okay so let's just
experience this okay try it but I would
normally keep you at these other drills
and then work on all kinds of
ways to deal with your
worldview that has you convinced that
contestation is the way the only way is
when I mean the way the only way okay so
let's try it so we just see this so
you're walking at them catching
internally you don't stop did I stop no
I'm just walking this is how I'm walking
I'm not walking like
this okay just walking
okay you start here and you walk towards
them they walk towards
you then UK can't alter yeah yeah you'll
alternate UK can't yield because you're
still our metric so don't take that
Force into your elbow okay what happens
when you do that is you went hyper Yen
and they're not going to notice that
that push them back okay
go there's that loock you see
yes do four four across two
more you stop you feel a stop and you
could see even your step drag where you
tried to put your weight onto that
foot there's the
turn okay so we'll go come back to
Maya and you're pushing
keep walking stopping keep going there's
that step did you see she did that okay
so's going to and again that that's this
that's this this okay the Desy is going
to use their their mouth and their
homolateral bracing structure that's
what you're trying to do when you fall
okay so we take that
away we're in this sheing you
do she's squishing and I'm not going for
up I don't have that bracing angle
anymore and I'm just
heree she can let go again let go when
you want and nothing happens okay the
next Dr I'm M her and I'm not going
backward this is the last two so um I
think you can do it one just hold two
okay because there's no movement you're
going to have to catch with your arm
catch with your arm bring your arm out
which I think helps amplify more that
you were bracing okay so hold in back
out okay
go and this concludes the standing set
for
good
and move to the center
please try it again two more
okay so do you feel the muscle tension
yes okay so it comes from you going
gooey to bring his hand back don't go
your hand comes back but it's not gooey
do you understand it just comes
back he he's not falling into the space
you're bringing him into the
space so slow down how much how he
comes just bring it
back then you bring it out now you're
closer slow him down don't lean at him
that's better m
that's fine this is better that you're
not turning
now you're not turning because you can't
okay that's what the drill is meant to
do just like I put that line on that
Shooter's grip it won't let her take her
hand apart you see say you can't turn
now and have it you turn now you're
going to go backwards
immediately and the tension is way gross
and the distinction between gooey and
tense is way gross you can tell so you
have toy you got to try to not go
gooey and not be tense you're just
moving
freely he's not the
metric he's not the metric what you're
doing inside you is the
metric so I'll show you when we're here
so we're going and we took away all her
mechanics okay we
go there's a little lean
there you're doing great
okay she's organizing all this to get it
back out and this is
closer regardless that she was projected
or not this is much closer than you were
moving her before with your just your
stiff arm okay the fact that you're not
going backwards as you're moving your
hand out is required you have to let go
of all that okay try it again we'll
watch you guys watch for this
there's a little
link you see she's she's releasing as
she's pushing out okay CU she has to um
if we had uh even a bigger dude you're
not it's not going to work
okay
um all right any uh let's stop there
again for talking point question
tooing yes I don't know I even when we
seem to be kind of listing in the right
direction the other day and I was I was
able to maintain someity I was feeling
uh you know not hardcore muscle
engagement but some pretty
palpable uh tension or pressure in the
shoulder area yes I don't know if that
meant to go away or not yeah um and yeah
I don't know I just I just find yes okay
so that was in drill two yeah and we had
a tendency to turn on drill to so let's
ourselves where we're not turning that's
what that's about and then the other as
we keep working we know okay I'm not
supposed to turn but it's possible to
maintain position in drill two without
actually fully doing drill two that's
why you need drill three and drill four
and you need to go on okay all of these
to to put it another way every single
drill can be done or
replicated under the untrained eye as if
you were doing it correctly that's why
you need the following through but if
you can't maintain positional Integrity
of at all with out this
stance we are further
behind than
somebody uh than where we need to be so
let me put that better
this is maintaining positional Integrity
you see I have this a frame okay and
this little skeletal alignment that I'm
using this looks like I'm doing the
drill but I took this away from you and
I said maintain structural Integrity
here positional Integrity here I need to
be able to do
this if I can't do it if I can only do
this if I can't do it here
then I am nowhere near being where I
need to be so I as a teacher just wanted
you to be able to maintain structural
Integrity cuz it's not so easy right cuz
you're you don't really have a base you
know what I mean and you don't really
have skeletal alignment because we're
not we're not I saw one ioka that he's
he's standing like this and the and you
know saying this is internals and this
just skeletal alignment you know
so it's still accomplishing a lot that
you're not
turning and I'll take it as a teacher
and then you know though
that I'm supposed to get rid of the
tension and then we keep working on that
tension and then you also know that the
shape doesn't matter so even on this
last drill
where you you can't turn yeah you
can you can turn you understand
just when I give you that pointer it's
like you're going to have to hold that
structal Integrity that I want you to be
able to hold without a
bracing we're going to go on the teacher
is going to go on and
go shape doesn't
matter you have to do it in any shape
and you have to do it moving it has to
function at the speed like or it's
nonfunction
and none of that becomes observable to
the self when you're just warming up
with these exercises it just it just
doesn't hence my emphasis on Partner
training okay so I'll take that not so
that's good right you were able to hold
that
um and then we just work there's more
drills there's more training to do keep
doing it um
just like everything's in the standing
it's just I'm not sure what I'm doing
here everything is in the positional
drill if you can truly do the positional
drill without any tension you can do all
the other drills I only need the other
drills to make more gross my deviation
from the standing drill okay um and so
you just that means then I'm going to
observe what I need to work on and I
need to work those things these drills
were just revealing to me they're not
really I think at one point I I said it
the way I always meant to say it but
it's eluding me they're not they're not
um
progressions they're just more
perspectives on the on the same skill
set okay um they're not like if you can
do this now that you did this do that
it's not NE that like you you've learned
addition now learn multiplication now
learn not it's not that kind of stuff
but it's just more perspectives that
give
you he said there is a ability to to
replicate the improper
mechanics okay but he also said there's
no shape And I need to do it moving and
I need do it at
life okay and that's how how to
understand this so I was very satisfied
that you came and you were able to be in
hni which is a very shallow stance right
it's a very shallow stance and on that
day hey cool you're holding there of
course there's tension there but better
than better than this and then we can
build on
that um but that is the the PO you set
is the boat rowing exercise just made
gross that
and now all that are in the techniques
so
um we had this
one here's that cat right
there so here's my
contestation and I'm not going to feat
it you let go that's go fine okay
catch it load
it and then project it
boom okay try
have to deviate now we have timing you
have
M this is just the Eco but we're going
to project him off of
us it's got to be
moving tension
free no gooey
my Center
out of your shoulder that's the same
turning it's not it's not it's not that
you're turning you turn it's not that
you turn the shoulder but you contest it
at the arm and that's where in the drill
it's exposes the turn okay
okay so we have this a discussion class
thank you
much push
push
push you see no gooey no gooey
okay
push no
gooey then we'll deal with the shoulder
tension so what happens is you come
here and then you tense
release just like in the in the drill
remember boom back forward no tension in
the arm coming back forward that's where
that happens so we
go even in what might be incorrect mind
you see I'm very tight just
release release
[Music]
release the
form
release small with release okay that
movement was that okay
try
it hard to do in the form easier to do
in the drill okay more simple and try it
keep the form don't do my little tricks
I'm just making points that the shape
does not matter
don't go
gooey or
tense did you feel the tension see
that's where it's
stall so you see now so now the teacher
presented Dilemma to you and it's how
serious you take it he did
that there was one R where he did that
so then why is this so
necessary do you get it yes so I maybe I
can't maybe I can't do it but
explain how that
worked you should be able to explain it
right so how did that work uh because
there
wasn't tension through the where where
did the repelling energy come from
because it's not coming from that
contestation on his GP and trying to
shove back because it's clearly not
there do you see that so where did the
displacing energy come from the rebound
from you letting in his initial aspect
got it and that's what's happening even
if I'm doing gross movements as AO which
I want you to do okay this is just a
demonstration like if you think you have
to do that struggle with this okay so
careful cuz right now on you we're
seeing the last
Str and it's got to be relaxed okay and
the more relaxed you are the more y
comes in the more y goes out the more it
displaces the mass and that rebounding
energy okay so you got to you got to try
harder I he's going to be there of
course he's there how are you going to
project him out if he's not there but
it's how do you move your hand in space
are you moving it all locked up or are
you just moving it okay so try it
again two more
part of it is your
immobility your immobility is uh is
triggering your ego tripartite mind you
go right into that what's going on with
your is it your knees or
what probably just some my hips more
than knees all right
that's better just keep it
relaxed you got to yield so there's that
I only know
gooey and then you got to find the
center not the arm not the shoulder cuz
the technique's in the center not in the
arm are you doing the mechanics if you
stay in the arm yes but the Kon is in
the center okay
and that that that that is the key hon
is you want his shoulder to pass you yes
there it is that's
it you get the claw
going good be on the balls of your feet
and get the inward spiral hand workk
going using all the internal mechanics
you just worked
on
right no need to come up we should be
going down when we throw
in y aspect going
down use the spiral don't Pro I'm going
to use the spiral
I made her the priz the priz is in the
[Music]
sh okay there's many ways to play with
it
you guys do the keyong
please and the keyho on the other side's
Not Dead side's
Alive
Center tension
no
no so remember I always say don't paint
right
so I'm not saying go to
tou I'm saying where you're op touch the
all
right get out of the
shoulder I can be low and being your
shoulder you get it yes do the
shape no find the center shoulder Center
okay do the shape in the center what
usually
happens is at a certain point in the
spiral that Center gets heavy so you
come up around the top of it you see no
Release Center
okay just like
other N Go in front of the whole Center
you're going around the top of the
center don't change the shape don't
touch the center the hand work is
exactly the same
right can you make sure he's
okay same thing U
Maya Center
that's it